[Música]
bueno
bajo
pero no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola cómo están
este puede decir mi historia en árabe
espero que entienden nada no creen
voy a entender y decirlo en español
voy a empezar mi plática con esta frase
que me gustó mucho
que dice donde haya humanidad hay todo
de este pequeño
mi familia se mudó a otra ciudad a
damasco al capital de seria por algunas
situaciones económicas
y en damasco vive el mayor parte de mi
vida
como un normal persona tenía casa amigos
familia trabajo tenía todo todos las
cosas principales que cada persona en
este el mundo debe que tener damascos el
hermoso
ciudad
esta ciudad tiene una historia de 2000
años por eso
el capital de siria damasco es el más
viejo en el mundo
en esta ciudad salía mucho con mis
amigos
me sentía en muchos lugares
tal como al pasar de mi día
el mosquito que se llama el móvil este
mosquito tiene una historia más de 500
mil años
el visite otros lugares con mis amigos
mi familia todo fui bien como un normal
persona
pero en un momento todo se cambió
desde el 15 del 15 de marzo 2012
el conflicto en serie se empezó
y ha llegado el día de hoy
mi vida y la vida de otras jóvenes
ha cambiado por una guerra civil
voy a decir como un joven
tenía 18 años
todo mi vida
[Música]
estaba viendo
una guerra
gente matan gente gente destruyen
ciudades escuelas ciudad de todo
distribuye en todo ciudades se bomba se
destruyen
en verdad tú no querías ser parte
está el guerra me dijo dos opciones el
primera opción que convertir mí mismo en
esta guerra empezar matar gente
distribuir escuelas
casas
matar sueños de miles de jóvenes
dejar todo
dejar mi casa mi familia mi estudio
mi amigo mis amigos dejar mi hogar y
salir como este es gente
este es que salieron no por porque
tienen hambre o porque necesitan mejor
vida
porque buscan la seguridad
ustedes qué harán si estaban en su
situación
él fue a irak como un reflejado
yo estaba en este el campo reflejado con
mi familia ustedes pueden imaginar 10
personas que viven en ese tamaño
pero no fui nada más me en mi familia
había otras historias niños mujeres
hombres que tienen peor que perdieron
personas
nada más que estamos acá que estábamos
sea yo lo que sería que estar esto que
sería que hacer algo más en vez de
trabajar trabajé muchos pesados trabajo
de un joven de 19 años
después de un año encontré un trabajo
que mi vida feliz trabajé con una
organización francesa que se llama acted
que ayuda a los refugiados sirios y
ayude los eyed peas era que años
este trabajo me da feliz porque estoy
trabajando trabajando y ayudando a demás
gente además gente que yo en sí yo
entiende que que tiene el mismo mi
situación
que piensan que quieren que tiene el
mismo sueño por eso me da gusto trabajar
con ellos
y
el futuro abro nuestro puerto para mí
porque conoce adrián meléndez adrián
meléndez es una persona del centro de
méxico de aguascalientes
ha trabajado en muchos países en el
mundo parte de áfrica asia europa el
trabajo en irak donde estaban viviendo
era mi jefe
es siempre me preguntaba ya que pasó
contigo cuéntame qué pasó por qué
saliste como la situación en tu país le
preguntaba una pregunta es diario ya qué
vas a hacer en tu futuro en mi única
respuesta fue yo quiero continuar mis
estudios porque yo siento que puedo
hacer algo con mis que con mis estudios
y adrián se fue corrió la idea para
hacer un proyecto para ayudar los
jóvenes decir ya que pueden continuar
sus estudios
ese fue y me dejó con me dejó tres años
con esperanza de pensamiento que voy a
tener la oportunidad para estudiar o no
un día me llamó me dijo jacques mahamat
todos listo ahorita ya tú puedes venir a
méxico ya tú puedes continuar tu
estudiar el verdad esta es noticia
estaba la única que me da feliz durante
esos cinco años que yo puedo yo puedo
continuar mis estudios
yo empecé a trabajar en mis papeles
en la fecha 14 de febrero 2017
fue otra fecha pero no fue una fecha
buena para mí porque ya voy a tener mi
oportunidad para estudiar
el viaje desde irak a grand slam ya que
la vida de méxico de grana mosco de
moscú la habana estoy viajando en el
mundo para un sueño que quiero estudiar
y llegué a ciudad de méxico con miedo
voy a ser honesto con miedo porque había
muchas noticias malas sobre méxico no
son buenos gente nos la país es peor no
tienen tecnología no tienen nada
pero yo quería querer reconocer porque
después mi experiencia en mi país
no voy a creer hasta que volver la
persona o vaya a ver la situación
cuando llegue el aeropuerto de méxico y
cuando vi el agente ya tenía mis propias
noticias pero buenas sobre méxico
méxico el hermosa país las hermosas
ciudades las amables gentes
empecé mi historia en méxico en
aguascalientes una ciudad muy chiquita
muy tranquila muy bonita en el centro de
méxico empecé a aprender la idioma
español y la cultura mexicana el día
después día yo am está el país más más
de más temas de más porque me trataron
muy bien yo siento que estoy en mi país
y mi hogar otra vez
y durante este año durante este lunar yo
no recibe un noticia muy buena de la
universidad de monterrey me dieron una
beca que ya puedo estudiar estoy aquí en
méxico para estudiar aquí soy yo
en el segundo semestre
en administración de empresas ud
la comunidad de audio siempre está a mi
lado para ser éxito siempre está a mi
lado para hacer para ser mejor persona
así como como si hubiesen allá en la
invertida de monterrey ser humano y ser
humano el cero de
en este orden desde las montañas de
monterrey ya puedo ver hacia dónde voy y
qué voy a hacer en el futuro ayudar a
demás gente
gente que estaba el mismo mi situación
que necesita ayudar para continuar sus
estudios para poder tomar la decisión de
su vida para poder pensar sobre el
futuro
en el final sorprende esta frase aprende
estas palabras son muy importantes es un
consejo para todos las personas que
están aquí que están viviendo ahorita
también
no importa de dónde eres de que deco al
país o de qué región eres el más importa
que somos en el final somos humanos
desde el proyecto sabella voy a decir
que el méxico
aquí no hay moros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]